leaked audio recordings attributed to
former prime minister nouri maliki are
trending in iraq
in this clip two men allegedly urged
maliki to take power by force and
eliminate his rivals
later they appear to pledge their
allegiance and offer maliki protection
from iran
there must be bloodshed in order for us
to take control this is recommended by
ayatollah mirza a blogger recently
published the clips on his twitter
account
in one maliki allegedly insults his
rival shia cleric mokta sadharyana
but releasing these recordings now means
the iranian role in healing the rift
between shia politicians is declining it
also indicates there's likely
disagreement between maliki and his
allies within the iranian-backed
coalition itself
today money maliki's office says the
recordings are fake
but the prosecutor has opened an
investigation
this development comes against the
backdrop of a heated dispute between
rival blocks about forming a government
maliki and his iranian-backed allies
want to form a consensus government
however
southern has rejected the group accusing
the politicians of corruption
has been deadlocked since october
legislative elections
unable to elect a new president
tensions escalated after 73 other
affiliated mps quit last month
southern maliki have exchanged the
statements encountered a statement
tweets and counter tweets
in a show of force suther summoned tens
of thousands of supporters to baghdad
for friday prayers
the preacher reiterated sadhara's
message of no partnership with
iranian-backed parties
the head of the pro-iran al-fattah
coalition had in amri has dismissed the
recordings
speaking at a shia religious event in
baghdad amri said they are aimed at
destabilizing iraq
but the blogger has promised to publish
more recordings with what he describes
as
more interesting content
that means the war of words between
iraqi politicians is unlikely to end
anytime soon
al jazeera
baghdad